Es ist soweit, wir sprechen über die 2. Liga der Männer im Rasenfunk. Endlich die Saison 2024-25. Jetzt erst hat sie offiziell begonnen mit dieser Ligatur. Wir wollen heute sprechen allgemein über die Liga und dann legen wir aber einen Schwerpunkt auf Schalke 04 und auf Darmstadt 98. Dazu habe ich zu Gast Matthias Kneifl und Dominik Slišković jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Und los geht's. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer und schön, dass ich meine Gäste hier begrüßen darf und dass, obwohl einer von ihnen sich die perfekte Rasenfunk-Streak zerschießt. Es ist Dominik Slišković. Ihn kennt ihr unter anderem, weil er bei der Ed Broski Show arbeitet. Und Dominik, du warst 04-mal im Rasenfunk. Dir selbst ist es aufgefallen. Und weil du offenbar wirklich unbedingt hier sein willst, machst du das jetzt kaputt und kommst zum 05-mal. Schön, dass du hier bist, alter Mainzer.
Lass mal beim Personal bleiben, weil ich finde, sportlich ist das so diffus, dass man da wirklich einfach sagen muss, da muss man eigentlich so die Segel streichen und sagen, so ähnlich, wie du es gerade eingeschätzt hast, komm, da müssen wir jetzt noch mal bis zur nächsten Länderspielpause in Ruhe draufgucken und dann kann man das besser bewerten. Aber es gab ja eben sehr viel Umbruch. Unter anderem ist Ben Manga mit seinem Team– ja, eingefallen ist jetzt so negativ besetzt– aber er ist aufgeschlagen bei Schalke 04. Da haben sich ja auch sehr viele drüber gefreut. Aber es war ja nicht der einzige Stuhl, der gerückt wurde bei Schalke 04. Kannst du uns mal zusammenfassen, was sind quasi die wichtigen Dinge, die sich verändert haben im Vergleich zur letzten Saison, die man mitbekommen haben muss?
Ja, ich glaube, Ben Manga ist auf jeden Fall die wichtigste Personalie, die im Sommer quasi geschehen ist. Und da würde ich auch alle Transfers quasi außen vor halten. Sondern da ist jetzt jemand reingekommen, der, wie du es gesagt hast, auch ein ganzes Team mitgebracht hat. Das war ja auch lange Zeit einfach ein Punkt oder eine Abteilung auf Schalke, die ein bisschen vernachlässigt oder so wie die Abteilung ist. Genau, das scouting. Da ist jetzt wirklich so eine Struktur drin. Es gibt bestimmte Personen, die bestimmte Märkte bedienen. Ich finde es auch sehr spannend, dass man so klar kommuniziert hat, okay, wir wollen jetzt folgendes Profil an Spiele scouten. Also jung U23 mit großem Potenzial, am besten schon mit Erstliga-Erfahrung in der Heimat, gerne auch aus Afrika und Südamerika. Da ist ja exemplarisch dieser Steve Noot, der aus dem Nichts gekommen ist, aus dem Cameroon, der noch nicht mal einen Transfer-Eintrag hatte und wo Ben Manga sich eben hinstellt und sagt, ich kenne den Jungen schon seit fünf Jahren und ich bin überzeugt von ihm. Und da gibt es ja einige Transfers. Und das ist eben auch nochmal diese Positivität, die zu Beginn der Saison um den Verein wahrzunehmen war, hingen ganz viel an dieser Personalie Ben Manga, weil es mal wieder den Fans vermittelt hat, da kommt jemand wirklich mit Fachexpertise. Also nicht jemand, der hausentern hochgezogen wurde, niemand, der irgendwie aus Klingelei in den Fall gekommen ist, sondern wirklich jemand, der Fachexpertise mitbringt, der Netzwerk mitbringt, der Weitsicht mitbringt. Und das hat, glaube ich, viele Leute angezündet. Und es gibt ja so einen kleinen Ausschnitt. Als Christopher Antwia Jay, glaube ich, war das seine Vertragsunterschrift auf Schalke hatte, wurde er natürlich von Schalker Vereinskameras begleitet. Und Christina Will-Hamas, die Finanzvorständin auf Schalke, hat ja vor allem in Boulevard etwas dunkles Bild, dunkles Image abbekommen, so von wegen sie spart Schalke Pleite und so weiter und so fort. Oh Gott, nee, ehrlich?
Das habe ich ja gar nicht mitgeschrieben.
Ja, ja.
Da kommt mal jemand mit finanzieller Expertise und einem sinnvollen Plan und dann heißt es– ach, das ist ja fantastisch.
Sie spart Schalke Pleite und sie will ja kein Geld freigeben. Und vor nichts kommt nichts. Und sie ist sowieso die große Hexe und wird Schalke zu runterrichten. Also, so nachdenklich davon, dass ich das so nicht glaube. Aber das ist quasi auch, was man dann halt so an Rumoren wahrnimmt, wenn man dann am Bergerfeld ist und irgendwie am Spieltag so den Fans lauscht. Aber auf jeden Fall gab es in dieser, sag ich mal, Doku zum Anfiya J, glaube ich, Transfer, eine sehr, also eine sehr, sehr kleine Szene, die dann aber der Schalker Bubble total angezündet wurde, weil Ben Manga irgendwie zu Anfiya J gesagt hat, hier, das ist die wichtigste Frau Schalke, stell dich gut mit ihr. Und Rülhamas dann so ein bisschen gekichert hat und irgendwie Ben Manga geknüpft hat und gesagt hat so, ach, hör doch auf, Ben. Und irgendwie so ein Alarm gesagt, ah ja, hier, der reißt den ganzen Laden rum und der hat Rülhamas jetzt auch angezündet für seine Idee und jetzt gibt es auch endlich wieder Geld. Und der nächste Moises Caicedo ist schon im Anflug. Und wir nehmen hier in drei Jahren schon wieder die Champions League aus am Ende, so wie halt Schalke.
Also eine Sache ist gleich geblieben, es reichen selbst kleinste Dinge, um wieder für euphorie zu sagen.
Genau so wie also kleinste Dinge auf Schalke herrscht jetzt auch große Begeisterung, weil der Verein sich dazu entschieden hat, Wasser an Spieltagen für zwei Euro anzubieten, statt 4,60 Euro, wie in der Vorsaison. Das ist aber gut. Super, da habe ich auch dankbar das Angebot angenommen, gerade bei den Temperaturen an den vergangenen Spieltagen. Aber da wurde halt auch schon wieder sehr theatralisch und sehr Schalke-esque nach außen verkauft. Der Verein hat es endlich verstanden und jetzt geht es voran. Wir sind der Konkurrenz voraus. Und wir blicken irgendwie schon in die Zukunft, während die anderen ihre Fans noch auseinandernehmen. Ausnehmen, genau, nicht auseinandernehmen, ausnehmen. Und da hat Ben Manga bestimmt auch seine Aktien drin. Also was man da nicht will, dass man aus solchen Kleinigkeiten rausliest.
Ich kenne Schalke gut genug, um zu fragen, wie heiß denn jetzt dieses Wasser? Ist es Grubenelexie oder was hat man sich dafür ausgedacht?
Oh, siehst du, vielleicht solltest du mal ein paar Leute in der Schalke-Marketing-Abteilung kontaktieren, weil so weit sind sie noch nicht gekommen. Also es ist immer noch das Wasser des Schalker Wassersponsoren. Aber das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, siehst du. Weil man hat ja auch in der vergangenen Saison bei Schalke gesehen, die bringen da so eine halbgarre Retro-Kollektion raus mit dem, mit so einem alten Logo und die Seite bricht zusammen und sie müssen irgendwie 10.000 Nachbestellungen machen. Die Leute warten vier Monate auf ihre bestellten Klamotten und dabei war es halt wirklich einfach nur quasi Adidas-Stangenware und da wurde das alte Logo drauf gekloppt. Aber der Verein ist halt so positiv gekloppt, dass du den Fans wirklich eigentlich alles verkaufen kannst, was auf der einen Seite eigentlich traurig ist, aber auf der anderen Seite auch, glaube ich, dass es wahrscheinlich immer noch am Leben erhält. Ja, das glaube ich auch. Um quasi den Kreis zu schließen. Ich glaube, deshalb kann so eine Person wie Ben Manga mit den Dingen, die er bis hierhin gemacht hat, eben auch so ein Umfeld anzünden und für sich gewinnen, weil sie halt einfach nach was Großen, nach der Zukunft, nach Erfolg lächzen. Und wenn eben jemand das gut zu verkaufen weiß, dann kommt er da mit, also auf Schalke, auf sehr näherhaften, nahhaften Boden.
Ja, also das muss man auf jeden Fall noch mal betonen. Also bei allem, ich habe mich jetzt ja auch lustig gemacht über diesen Marketingkram, der da auf Schalke eben sehr häufig passiert ist, vor allem in der Vergangenheit natürlich. Aber 164 Millionen Euro Rohergebnis in der Saison 2022-23, das war das zehntbeste Ergebnis im deutschen Profifußball. Daher kommt überhaupt die Möglichkeit, drei Jahre in der 2. Liga finanzieren zu können. Denn ansonsten wissen wir ja, die Schulden sind ebenso riesig bei Schalke 04. Aber wenn eben vorne die ganze Zeit was reinkommt, dann kannst du hinten auch deine Kredite bedienen und ein bisschen was noch verbrennen in deinem Personaletat. Jetzt ist das aber natürlich zweischneidig zu sehen. Also Ben Manga hat natürlich einen sehr guten Track-Racket. Also er war vorher beim VfB Stuttgart, vor allem bei Eintracht Frankfurt. Da hat er richtig mit seinen mit von ihm gescouteten Spielern eine Ära geprägt. Die Wortvorzeit habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so wirklich verfolgt. Da kann ich mir keinen Urteil zu erlauben. Aber es liegt ja auch eine kleine Gefahr darin, wenn man sich so jemandem und seinem Team– ich weiß nicht, ob Auslieferung zu viel ist. Wie würdest du darauf blicken, auf ein Abhängigkeitsverhältnis, was man definitiv hat?
Ja, absolut. Das sind die Verfehlungen in der Vergangenheit, dass man sich grundsätzlich sich in scouting schon besser aufgestellt hat und generell in der sportlichen Leitung besser aufgestellt hat. Ich finde es erstmal grundsätzlich gut, dass man eben Ben Manga plus Team geholt hat, weil es eben eingespielt ist. Du ein ganz großes Netzwerk aktivieren kannst. Also nicht wieder eine Person, die quasi von scouting bis Ansprache und Vertragsabschluss alles machen muss, sondern dass du das auf viele Schultern aufteilst. Aber natürlich besteht die Gefahr, Ben Manga verwirft sich mit Vorstandsvorsitzenden Tillmann und ist in sechs Monaten wieder weg und dann natürlich mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit auch sein ganzes Team und du stehst wieder bei Null. Aber die Frage ist ja, was wäre die Alternative gewesen? Also es war ja schon gegen Ende der vergangenen Saison klar, dass Ben Manga kommt und da war ja auch klar, ohne sein Team kommt er eben nicht. Also er wird nicht alleine kommen. Da wurde dann ja peu à peu die Schalker scouting-abteilung mehr oder weniger aufgelöst. Also ein Mitarbeiter nach dem anderen ging, bis quasi sozusagen eine weiße Fläche entstanden ist, auf der dann Ben Manga anfangen konnte zu malen und seine Musiksteine zu setzen. Und dementsprechend war Schalke einfach in so einer Verhandlungssituation oder generell in so einer sportlichen Situation, dass das, glaube ich, egal wie die Saison jetzt weiterläuft, aber stand heute, die beste Entscheidung war, so eine fähige Person plus Netzwerk reinzuholen und dann eben zu hoffen, einfach, dass es drei Jahre plus hält und eben nicht das nächste Gasspiel ist. Weil das hatten wir jetzt auf Schalke zu Hauf, sei es ein André Hechelmann gewesen, sei es ein Jochen Schneider, noch ein Christian Heidel, das war ja alles nicht von Dauer. Und ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass dieser Schattenung von Rudi Assauer dann doch mit der Zeit jetzt abnimmt, weil man auch eben sieht, der Fußball hat sich so massiv entwickelt, dass so eine Persönlichkeit wie Assauer da immer weniger Platz hätte, also einfach diese Alleinherrschaft, diese Geballte macht. Gar nicht jetzt so eher als Charakter. Ich glaube, der wird in der Presse und bei den Fans weiterhin punkten. Aber man merkt halt eben auch, dass Schalke als sehr traditionelles Umfeld immer sozusagen offener ist für solche Ansätze, für so etwas Dezentrales, wie es eben Manga fährt. Und da war ja auch zu Anfangszeit, also auch bevor Manga wirklich offiziell vorgestellt wurde, war ja da auch schon das Getuschel groß. Wie wird er mit Mark Wilmots zusammenarbeiten? Mark Wilmots ist ja offiziell Sportdirektor. Ben Manga ist, glaube ich, Direktor scouting und Knappenschmiede. Und dabei auch dann lange gut gemunt, was, ok, berichtet er an Mark Wilmots. Wird Mark Wilmots sich quasi enteignet fühlen durch Ben Manga, der eigentlich ihm alles zuarbeitet. Und Mark Wilmots kommt dann nur zu den Fotoshootings mit den neuen Spielern. Wie soll das funktionieren? Und da ist ja eigentlich recht positiv wahrzunehmen, dass die beiden offenbar, zumindest so, wie ich es einschätzen kann, einen sehr offenen Diskurs führen. Es relativ wenig echte Alleingänge gibt von Ben Manga. Und Mark Wilmots ihn ja auch tatsächlich in der ganzen Manga-Gerads-Posse– nächster Spoiler– doch den Rücken stärkt oder ihm zumindest nicht in den Rücken fällt, wo er auch lange getuschelt wurde. Okay, Wilmots und Gerads, zwei Belgier, die, so weit ich weiß, sogar noch zusammen in der Nationalmannschaft gespielt haben, also die sich kennen und schätzen, da wird auch Wilmots bestimmt zu seinem Landsmann halten, so wie das halt so ist. Und das scheint ja überhaupt nicht der Fall zu sein, sondern Wilmots tritt, was man jetzt auch in der vergangenen Saison gar nicht so gedacht hätte, als recht besonderer Mittler auf, was ich als überraschend gute Entwicklung, Charaktereinwicklung wahrnehme, weil so nach den ersten Wochen Marc Wilmots Sportdirektor gerade in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung dachte ich, uiuiui, was haben sie denn da bloß gemacht? Weil das war ja phasenweise, also ich wusste ja gefühlt nicht, was er gestern erzählt hat und hat sich dann selbst widersprochen. Und ich glaube, da ist er dann auch in diese Rolle gut reingewachsen.
Okay, aber was ist denn jetzt dann los mit Karel Gerrits? Was ist die Kritik? Was weiß man? Ist es jetzt hier auch wieder nur Boulevard oder ist da was dran? Ich habe es ehrlicherweise nur so ganz am Rande mitbekommen.
Also der Kern dieser ganzen Posse ist, dass Ben Manga zwei junge, talentierte Innenverteidiger verpflichtet hat. Philippe Sanches und Martin Vazinski. Philippe Sanches aus meiner Sicht eigentlich ein Spieler vom Profil Königstransfer. Hat zwei Jahre erst argentinische Liga schon in den Beinen bei Gymnasia La Plata, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Martin Vazinski auch U20-Nationalspieler Belgiens. Hat auch schon erste Liga-Erfahrung bei Charleroi, wenn ich richtig informiert bin, ja. Und Ben Manga ist sehr begeistert von den Beinen, also ist sehr vokal in seiner Erzeugung von diesen Spielern. Und hat gerade auch, weil jetzt Thomas Kallasch, der sich ja letzte Saison als absoluter Abwehrchef herausgespielt hat, verletzungsbedingt länger ausfällt, die beiden auch so ein bisschen in die Position gebracht, verbal in Richtung Presse. Wir haben ja zwei junge Spieler, die lauern ja nur auf diese Chance. Diese Chance haben sie von Karel Gerač bisher nicht wirklich bekommen. Karel Gerač setzt lieber auf Ibrahim Assisi, der ja schon zwei Trainer vor ihm zu Weißblut und Verzweiflung gebracht hat, weil er zwar ein hoch veranlagter Spieler, aber ein Spieler, der eben jetzt, glaube ich, in der dritten Saison auf Schalke nicht auf ein konditionelles und auch auf ein taktisches Niveau kommt, dass er wirklich unangefochtener Stammspieler wäre. Daneben lässt er Ron Schallenberg spielen in der Innenverteidigung, den er quasi die verlangene Saison umgeschult hat, vom Sechser zum Innenverteidiger, der das sehr gut gemacht hat, der auf Schalke so eine Libereau-Position einnimmt, also oftmals auch ohne direkten Gegenspieler agiert in der Verteidigung, den Spielaufbau von sehr tief, also gefühlt direkt vom Torwart, bekommt den Ball, ankurbelt. Und darauf hat sich eben Gerards eingespielt. Und man hat eben sowohl gegen Köln als auch in Magdeburg und schon gegen den Klub gesehen, das ist halt nicht ganz sattelfest. Und Ben Manga, da kann man ihn jetzt diskutieren, aus meiner Sicht auch so ein bisschen unnötigerweise, dann nochmal vor die Presse gestellt und gesagt, explizit zu Philippe Sanches, ein Spieler, der gegen Boca Juniors im Bomboleira spielt und über 90 Minuten spielt, der will schon kein Problem haben, gegen Magdeburg oder in Magdeburg oder gegen den 1. FC Köln aufzulaufen. Und das aus meiner Sicht so ein bisschen die Entscheidung des Trainers kritisiert und den Trainer aus meiner Sicht ja auch ein wenig damit angezählt, weil er sagt, er oder ich habe daraus rausgelesen, Ben Manga traut dem Trainer nicht zu, das Potenzial der Spieler korrekt einzuschätzen. Karel Geraz hat dann wiederum gesagt, das sind nicht seine Worte. Er sieht das, was jeden Tag auf dem Platz geschieht und keiner macht sich so viele Sorgen und nimmt sich Schalke 04 wie er. Und er wird niemanden jetzt protigieren, weil es von außen hereingetragen wird. Er will seine Entscheidung finden. Und jetzt ist quasi die große Erwartung, was wird gegen den KSC jetzt am Wochenende passieren. Wird das Wiederassist Schallenberg heißen in der Innenverteidigung? Geraz bleibt sich treu und vertraut den Spielern, denen er ihm vertrauen möchte. Oder wird er vielleicht doch einlenken und Wasinski oder Sanchos mal von Beginn an Minuten in der Liga ergeben? Die beiden haben ja ein Pokal von Beginn an gespielt. Wasinski hat jetzt unter der Woche im Testspiel gegen Nagbreda oder vergangene Woche im Testspiel gegen Nagbreda auch gespielt. Hat das eine Gegentor mit einem Stoppfehler günstigt, dann aber sein Fehler selbst mit einem guten Pressing-Verhalten wieder gut gemacht und eigene Treffer zum Sieg. Ich bin also auch ein bisschen zuwiegespalten, weil ich auf der einen Seite eigentlich schon einen starken Trainer haben möchte, der sagt, ich habe meine Vorstellung, ich vertraue auf mich und das, was ich eben auch im Training sehe und ich lasse mich nicht reinreden. Andererseits kann ich es aber auch nachvollziehen, wenn man sagt, okay, er hat dieses Spielermaterial, was aus meiner Sicht absolut zweitligafähig ist, was sich angeboten hat, mit guten Leistungen im Pokal und in den Testspielen und er setzt so gar nicht darauf, gerade eben, wenn er sieht, dass die Innenverteidigung, wie sie jetzt in den vergangenen drei Spielen war, nicht sattelfest ist. Er hat heute in der Spieltags-PK, als die Frage wieder zu den Innenverteidiger-Duo, Innenverteidiger-Pärchen kam, gesagt, na ja, er wird sich seine Gedanken machen und er kann auch verstehen, wenn die Leute sagen, dass man da nicht sattelfest war. Aber eine Innenverteidigung wird auch nicht sattelfester, wenn man sie in vier Wochen dreimal wechselt. Das klang jetzt für mich erstmal so raus, als ob wir dann gegen den KSC wieder das Innenverteidiger-Pärchen Cissé und Schallenberg bekommen. Sollten sie zu Null spielen, Schalke gewinnt gegen den KSC, dann wird sich Geraz natürlich auch zurecht hinstellen und sagen, ich habe es dir gesagt, gib mir Zeit, ich weiß, was ich mache. Wenn Schalke da wieder zwei oder drei Gegentore kassiert, dann wird die Hütte, glaube ich, ganz anders brennen, weil dann der Druck auf Geraz sowohl mit Blick auf die Tabelle als auch, dann kann man es ihm halt auch als Sturheit auslegen, ein bisschen größer werden dürfte.
Also, dass das inhaltlich natürlich eine valide Debatte ist, die auch letztlich an die zukünftige Strategie von Schalke heranrührt, das, denke ich, kann man sehr leicht verargumentieren. Aber warum, Dominik, muss das denn öffentlich stattfinden? An wem liegt das?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich habe ja gerade gesagt, also ich fand diese Aussage von Manga mit Sanches, der wird ja wohl gegen Wachtelburg spielen können, war nicht ein bisschen übers Ziel hinausgeschossen. Unterm Strich, glaube ich, wissen wir halt alle, wie das Umfeld auf Schalke ist. Da laufen halt mehr als zwei… Also liegt es an den Medien.
Kann man sowas nicht intern machen?
Ich glaube, der Mediendruck auf Schalke ist auf jeden Fall ein anderer als oder größerer als bei anderen Zweitliga-Standorten. Und wenn dann Ben Manga eben drei, vier Fragen ausweichen kann, wird dann halt der Druck vielleicht so groß, dass er in der fünften Frage oder auf die fünfte Frage mit Klartext antwortet oder mit so viel Klartext, wie er sich leisten kann in seiner Position. Ja, ich glaube, wir werden nie zu dem Umstand kommen, dass auf Schalke über– es sind ja dann doch auch sportliche Themen– so gar nicht in der Öffentlichkeit mit Aussagen von Verantwortlichen debattiert, diskutiert wird. Ich glaube, das ist utopisch, weil eben, wie gesagt, da laufen so viele Medienvertreter rum, das interessiert so viele Leute. Natürlich wissen auch die Verantwortlichen, dass sie sich da profilieren können durch bestimmte Aussagen, dass sie bestimmte Stimmungen bedienen können. Und ich glaube, wir werden dann, wie gesagt, nie dazu kommen, dass es so eine Diskussion aus Fernkreisen gibt und da es komplette Stille am Jens-Von-Zorra-Weg geben wird und dass das dann einfach totgeschwiegen wird. Weil dann, glaube ich, ist sogar die Gefahr größer, dass der Boulevard sein eigenes Süppchen daraus kocht und das dann wieder heißt ja Schalke schweigt und was bedeutet das und das kann nichts Gutes bedeuten. Und das gab es bestimmt schon mal in der Vergangenheit und da ist das und das passiert und das blüht uns jetzt auch.
Also ich verstehe deinen Punkt und da ist ganz sicherlich was wahres dran, aber ich finde es schon bemerkenswert, dass Schalke da in eine Situation reingekommen ist, in der es auf jeden Fall mindestens einen Verlierer geben wird. Wahrscheinlich sogar mehr und das kann sein, dass das beteiligte Spieler sind, sowohl diejenigen, die spielen sollen, als auch die, die jetzt gerade spielen. Es ist relativ wahrscheinlich, dass es der Trainer ist, Karol Gerrads, denn das ist eine Kompetenzüberschreitung von Ben Manga. Sowas geht auf Dauer nie gut im Fußball, das kann man so sagen. Und ehrlicherweise finde ich auch, dass Ben Manga dann vielleicht mal ein Interview weniger geben könnte. Also wobei, ich möchte anerkennen, was du sagst. Also es stimmt natürlich, dass es bei Schalke schwierig ist, Dinge unter der Decke zu halten, aber es gibt immer die Option, es gibt die Option, nichts zu sagen. Und selbst wenn der Boulevard, in Anführungszeichen, sich dann was ausdenkt, dann lasst sie sich was ausdenken. Also ich erlebe es gerade, wie es hier ist. Beim FC Bayern, also ich bin ja in München ansässig. Ich weiß nicht, ob er es durchhalten kann, aber Marseille Compagnie hat auf die ersten 15 Fragen nach möglichen Transfers, hat er immer gesagt, das ist ein Thema, da werde ich nichts zu sagen. Und mehr hat er nicht dazu gesagt. 15 Mal, in verschiedenen Variationen. Und tatsächlich irgendwann hat es aufgehört. Jetzt muss Max Eberl häufiger in den Mixed Zone, weil natürlich die MedienvertreterInnen haben trotzdem ihre Fragen. Aber das fand ich interessant, weil der Kontrast auch zu Thomas Tuche so groß war. Und wie gesagt, jetzt mit aller Vorsicht muss man mal gucken, kann er das auch durchhalten, wenn es richtig brennt hier in München beim FC Bayern und so weiter und so fort. Aber es ist schon möglich zu sagen, äußere ich mich nicht zu, das machen wir nur intern, naja.
Ja, ich glaube, du hast da also viele Sachen angesprochen, die sich halt in dieser Gemengelage befinden. Also man muss Schalke schon auch so gut halten, dass viele Transfers kaum, gar nicht, sehr spät an die Presse durchgesteckt worden sind.
Ja, sehr gut.
Also der heiße Moussa Sila oder Janik Bachmann hat auch keine auf dem Schirm. Adrian Gantenbein wurde super schnell, super früh bekanntgegeben.
Ist eh mein Lieblingsspieler bei euch. Mein Name ist ja Gantenbein, aber das ist hin.
Also von daher glaube ich, machen sie das alles in einem besser als in den vergangenen Zeiten auf Schalke. Aber wie gesagt, ganz die Presse nicht bedienen, wird auf Schalke nicht funktionieren. Und ich glaube halt, wie gesagt, diese eine Aussage von Manga mit Philippe Sanches, Wasinski, das war ein ganz klarer Ausrutscher. Ich glaube, das wird er in seinem stillen Kämmerlein auch als solcher, reflektiert haben. Ich glaube, bei ihm kam halt in dem Moment vielleicht auch so ein bisschen Frustration durch, weil Peratz natürlich auch mit Mangas Strategie spielt, indem er sie halt nicht einsetzt oder kaum einsetzt. Ich habe es ja vorhin schon aufgezeichnet, dass es eben Ben Mangas selling point, ich komme rein, ich bringe euch in ruhigem Fahrwasser mittelfristig wieder dorthin, wo ihr hingehört, als einer der größten Vereine Deutschlands, als einer der Mitglieder stärksten Vereine Europas. Und wenn Karel Gerrads sagt, das ist ja alles schön und gut, aber ich sehe die beiden nicht als Spieler, die in mein System passen, wenn es eine Systemfrage sein sollte. Und Philippe Sanches wird halt nicht, wie prognostiziert, in ein bis zwei Jahren für 10 bis 15 Millionen verkauft werden, sondern wird jetzt im Winter oder im Sommer an den anderen Zweitligisten verliehen und startet vielleicht nicht durch. Und es kommt halt nicht zu dieser Marktwertentwicklung, die dann halt für Schalke barees Geld bedeutet. Dann muss ich eben Ben Manga auch anhören, okay, vielleicht bist du eben nicht das diamanten Auge, als das bei uns verkauft wurde und als das du dich präsentiert hast. Ich finde halt, nach vier Spieltagen schon so in die Offensive zu gehen, ein verheerendes Zeichen, weil da ja eigentlich Ben Manga gezeigt hat, wie weit es bei ihm mit Geduld ist, die er eigentlich dann nach außen predigt.
Ja, stimmt. Das ist eine nette Poarte. Und das ist interessant. Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass wir über Schalke jetzt länger reden als über Darmstadt, weil ich mir dachte, so viele Themen gibt es ja gerade gar nicht. Und doch gibt es auch so Parallelen, die nicht absolut gleich sind, aber diese schnelle Unruhe, diese Unfähigkeit, die nachvollziehbare Unfähigkeit, also es ist nicht als Vorwurf gemeint, eben Geduld zu haben. Gleichzeitig aber auch, dass man sich immer wieder implizit und manchmal auch explizit an Vereinen orientiert, die dann doch diese Geduld haben. Also Matthias, wenn du eben checkst, wie lange sind die Zweitligatrainer denn bei ihren Vereinen, dann kann ich nicht, um hinzuglauben, dass das auch damit zusammenhängt, dass dein Verein in Anführungszeichen eben gerade wieder seinen Trainer gewechselt hat. Also interessant.
Wobei man sagen muss, die Ligen hatte ich gerade nochmal mich rückversichert. Das letzte Mal, dass sie einen Trainer entlassen hatten, war 2019. Seitdem sind sie schon sehr beharrlich an ihrem Trainerpersonal geblieben. Und wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass tatsächlich auch das fast ein Lieberknecht einen Anteil an der Trennung jetzt hatte, dann ist es eben seit fünf Jahren so, dass der Verein nur sehr ungern irgendwie eine Konsequenz zieht. Es lief ja auch lange genug gut oder so, dass man zumindest nicht große Sorgen haben musste. Die Erstligasaison ging in die Hose. Da haben auch sicherlich die Entscheider über den Trainer ihren Anteil dran. Aber ich denke, das ist etwas, was Kohfeldt jetzt sicherlich auch zu pass kommt. Das hat man vorhin schon angedeutet. Er findet hier ein ruhiges Umfeld vor, gleichwohl. Eines, das schon mittlerweile sehr sensibilisiert ist, weil aus der ersten Liga abzusteigen, kann man einpreisen. Die Anweise war überhaupt nicht gut. Das macht auch was mit dem Umfeld. Wenn man quasi so als verschlechster Absteiger der Bundesliga-Historie verschrien wird, dann ist es auch etwas, was deutschlandweit das Image nicht gerade befördert. Aber jetzt gucken wir mal. Jetzt ist jeder so ein bisschen auf heißen Kohlen und hofft, dass der Umschwung kommt. Gleichwohl mit zwei wirklich wichtigen Spielen, die verletzt sind. Das wird alles andere als ein Selbstläufer. Ich glaube, das war vielen klar oder viele haben es befürchtet und jetzt scheint es tatsächlich so zu werden. Und ich hoffe, dass wir kein Bielefeld nachmachen, sondern eher Schalke, die ja letztes Jahr sich auch dann auch rausgezogen haben aus dem Strudel. Und eine personelle Verbindung gibt es tatsächlich zwischen den Ligen und den Schalken und zwar Yannick Bachmann. Er war in Darmstadt in der Jugend, fünf Jahre lang. Und ich glaube, er ist jetzt nicht so ein typischer Spieler, den man Ben Manga zuschreibt. Deshalb keine Ahnung, wie er nach Schalke gekommen ist. Er verkaufte ja was anderes als ein Spieler, der irgendwann mal für viel mehr Geld verkauft wird. Also er ist sicherlich ein Stabilisator, würde ich mal annehmen. Ich habe ihn jetzt noch nicht gesehen, in Königsblau. Aber ich glaube, er ist etwas, was den Königsblauen Anhang auch durchaus zusagt, wenn er gerne mal etwas Rustikale aufräumt.
Ja, vor allem hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass er so eine prägende Rolle einnimmt im Team. Also ich hätte eher gedacht, dass er mehr von der Bank kommt, aber er ist ja eigentlich seit Minute eins gesetzt als Zerstörer und Störenfried im Mittelfeld.
Du benenzt es völlig falsch. Holding Six. Dann ist er gleich 5 Millionen Euro teurer.
Ja, okay. Aber dann müssten wir ihn nicht Janik Bachmann, sondern Joao Bagmanio nennen oder so. Dann können wir ihn auch für 45 Millionen zum FC Bayern transferieren nächste Saison.
So schaut es nämlich aus. Aber ich glaube, man kann abschließend sagen, es sind…
Entschuldigung, Max, da komme ich noch mit einem Fun Fact um die Ecke, wo du gerade schon mir die Bühne bereitest, Dominik. Und zwar Janek Bachmann heißt offiziell Janik J. Bachmann. Und ich weiß von einem sehr guten Freund, der aus demselben Dorf stammt, wie Janik Bachmann oder zumindest aus einem benachbarten Dorf, dass der Vater glühender Eintracht-Fan ist und Janik Bachmann JJ. Bachmann nennen wollte, was beim Standesamt nicht durchging oder beim Geburtsregister. Und deshalb heißt er Janik J. Bachmann. Also JJ. Okocsa hat irgendwo auch seine Spuren bei Janik Bachmann hinterlassen. Vielleicht geht da noch was auf dem Transfermarkt.
Ich bin mal gespannt, gegen welchen Torhüter JJ. Okoccas Jahrhundertor dupliziert.
Also wenn er es tut, dann mit Grätschen, aber nicht mit Übersteigern. Aber es wird genauso spektakulär. Aber das ist nämlich genau der Punkt. Ich glaube, abschließend kann man sagen, bei beiden Teams, sowohl bei Darmstadt 98 als auch bei Schalke, lohnt es sich jetzt drauf zu blicken, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Bei den einen, weil sie mutigen Fußball spielen wollen, was noch nie jemand spielen wollte. Da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Und sollte die Abwehr nicht stabilisiert werden, wird immer was passieren bei Darmstadt spielen. Das kann man sagen. Und bei Schalke 04 hat man eben diese viele unbekannten Spieler. Wir beachten jetzt natürlich sowieso immer nur noch auf die Innenverteidigung. Torhüter haben wir jetzt gar nicht thematisiert, aber es wird ja noch öfter um Schalke gehen in dieser Saison. Aber es gibt eben diese vielen Spieler, die wirklich das Potenzial bieten zu träumen und wo man eben dann– also da verstehe ich jeden Schalke-Fan und das ist ja auch das Schöne daran– jeder Neuzugang ist potenziell Ballon d'Or-Gewinner der Zukunft. Und erst nach 10, 15 Spielen gesteht man ihnen zu, ach nee, ach deswegen spielst du hier.
Wobei wir unseren künftigen Ballon d'Or-Gewinner ja jetzt zum Waldhof abgegeben haben in Henning-Bandricciani.
Ja, okay, gut. Aber das ist doch nur eine Laie, oder? Da kommt er doch wieder. Wird er jetzt nicht veredelt vom Waldhof? Kennt man nicht da für den Waldhof?
Man munkelt ja, dass Schalke sich nicht unbedingt wünscht, dass er zurückkommt. Aber mal schauen.
Na gut, was soll man sagen? Ihr zwei, dass die Folgen kürzer werden, das hat nicht geklappt. Aber es hat auf jeden Fall geklappt, dass wir tief bei euren Vereinen rangegangen sind. Und wir haben immer noch nicht alles besprochen. Deswegen wird der Rasenfunk immer so lang. Ich sag's euch, liebe Leute. Aber ich danke euch sehr für eure Zeit. Herzlichen Dank an Matthias Kneifl. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es weitergeht bei Darmstadt. Danke dir, lieber Matthias.
Ich auch, vielen Dank.
Und herzlichen Dank an Dominik Slišković. Schön, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Und jetzt können wir es ja bis zu 44 auf jeden Fall schon mal durchziehen, also zu deinem 44.
Auftritt. Ich bitte doch darum. Vielen Dank.
Ja, danke dir auch für deine Zeit. Und ich möchte auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, danken. Zum einen für euer Feedback, dass ihr uns bitte gebt auf diese Folge unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und in allen sozialen Netzwerken eurer Art. Bitte bewertet auch gerne den Rasenfunk bei der Podcastplattform Eure Wahl. Das habe ich schon ganz lange nicht mehr gesagt. Und empfiehlt uns weiter. Dieser Ligatour-Feed ist sehr beliebt bei allen, die ihn kennen, aber ihn kennen immer noch sehr wenige. Also empfiehlt diese Folge, postet sie in entsprechenden Formen und so weiter und so fort. Und unterstützt uns auch sehr gerne finanziell. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist werbe-, payable und sponsorenfrei und wird allein von euch finanziert. Und da sind unter anderem mit dabei Max aus Oslo, Hans Kovac, Bahnchef AD, Jonathan, Kilian und nico. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club gegangen und haben uns dort finanziell unterstützt. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Bleibt gesund, bleibt dem Rasenfunk treu. Nächste Woche geht es hoffentlich an dieser Stelle mit der europäischen Ausgabe weiter. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund. Bis bald. Ciao. Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.